anyway life goes on so yeah again my
games have been lasting a while so
really not too much opportunity to
interact with the chats but I hope the
chat can interact with themselves if
you're watching in the future on YouTube
say hi to the twitch chats interact with
each other in the comments okay so we're
gonna have some I think this is a first
like Queen's Gambit game of the
tournament pointed taking time oh I'm
playing I'm playing Carlos this is
Carlos right yeah this Carlos I think HT
l stands for Atlanta take Carlos in
ping-pong within the last year I think
very nice person
[Music]
also played him I play them in tennis
with I'll try and find the picture after
it's played tennis with him MVL and
someone else okay so we have a line I
played a bunch of blitz with him too
like over the board at the same who's
chess club but I forget our games
I can't remember like a single opening
from our blood schemes
I would imagine that maybe I played this
against him at some points this is my
main thing but maybe I was playing blew
the pass against him I don't know
I'll see what he's up to
I played the song a lot against Ben
Feingold it been handled it very well
our Bishop takes f6 not the most typical
move but it's playable I mean a simple
plan for whites some people try just to
go crazy in the tack the drawback for a
white that gives me the bishop hair so
okay yeah he doesn't want to attack so
very often it makes sense to open the
position with a move like c5 see if I
might just give Y the free pawn must be
precise
there's also beef I like be fine before
in Queen c2 why is cuz I can't play
Bishop a5 yet in Bishop g4 is some some
idea see there's a funny move here
there's a funny move that sets up a trap
it's it's not quite a trap
hey Erick Rosen's playing
Carlos that's Carlos his name Carlos
debating between b5 and rookie AIDS it
probably doesn't make a huge difference
or see father mean his plan is varied
like I know his next few moves so I'm
trying to figure out my next funeral one
of our chess club members Carlos Perdomo
as his own chess company here in Atlanta
competes with us he's playing Eric Rosen
the guy who made our website I am double
forfeit
that'll show them no favorites like I
don't know if that makes sense
I think c5 is a concrete way of playing
ok c5 he probably takes should calculate
c5 takes Queen a5 counseling it's a
small issue though in Bishop e6 there
should be six Bishop d3 h6
that's probably the way like not seeing
anything super concrete but intuitively
I think this is a way to go
and yeah I'm playing this move after
just checking that it doesn't fail
immediately it was one concerned with
chief I was gonna be week after takes
but there's a line pawn takes pawn queen
a5 castling and then just Bishop e6 and
why probably can't take on d5 because I
I take or even take on e2 by the way
probably take first and then take on a2
and the king was just too weak F white
doesn't take then there's c4 ideas and
c4 will control d3 yeah so let's play
Queen a5 it's gonna be sharp though
expecting Queens like castling yeah I
was also like I guess the main line I
looked at was castling vision 6 Bishop
d3 h6h 6 does allow for some eventual g4
g5 but it takes some time for white to
prepare and ideally I want to win back
the pawn with a rook I want to play rook
probably rook FC 8 or even knight c6 a
few ideas for the knight knight c6
Knight before or 97 and then take with a
knight and yeah the Queen is very useful
here pressures upon pins and light and
in the event of of white castling the
knee choose of the tender
and just intuitively don't know how
obvious is is just so many people but
the whole point of c5 was to open the
position for this Bishop because white
doesn't have a dark spirit Bishop so
even if I don't end up winning the pawn
there some like long-term compensation
of course the downside I mean this is
isolated pawn and white might have 94 at
some points he might be considering just
Bishop e2 in kingside castling Bishop d3
first okay so it's really a question
between h6 or each 6 for g6 now Carlos
said I shouldn't tell you this but he
legally changed his name to Carlos spicy
Weiner oh snap anybody know probably h6
I actually wasn't sure there may be g6
made more sense to Bishop g7 would have
allowed like more possibilities with h4
h5 but in this case I also restrict the
knight a bit more so there's no like h4
Knight g5 probably expecting this I take
maybe um maybe castling there's there's
Bishop e6 they shoes Knight 94 and we
might get the structure it takes takes
takes where I have three pawn islands of
two pawns each so not super pretty but
very playable have some a file action
there have some Center pawns its bits
from e r WT 64 thanks for the bits
saying black adorns you what's the
difference between adorns and adores
okay let's let's stay focused I have a
nice time damage black always referring
to black and white the locks up two
minutes I'm up two minutes now over two
minutes as we saw last game time is
relevant so I think I will play Bishop
e6 cuz I was okay with thumb ooh there's
a trick though I play Bishop e6 there's
rook C one takes oh there's no yeah
there's no Knight takes d5 cuz Queen
takes d5 I guess there's Knight a four
okay Bishop e6 mind a 497 hmm it could
be slightly annoying a 490 73 I might
have to take like I wanted to do this 94
97 83 and the question is I actually
stopped before alright the more you
donate the more money we have to throw
these tournaments also caring wants to
go shopping occasionally for food we
never get any toilet paper but we'd like
to okay ooh
and if I Taylor's 90 for a long before
clever move I might just be suffering
here I'm not seeing a clear solution I
mean I could be very concrete and just
take which makes actually make some
sense if pawn takes okay I'm fine
playing that structure if Queen takes we
trade Queens and then I play ninety
seven guaranteeing to win this pawn and
there's no immediate counter-attack I
think that's why I want to go for it
seems so weird like to trade I got down
upon undeveloped but my pieces come to
life very quickly and whites well it's
not seizing so much initiative we might
end up seeing like takes takes takes 97
c6
okay that's playable
yeah the structure I'm flying with
because I do have this pawn and White
has good control over d4 but this pawn
is some also weakness which is probably
why I play c4 trying to capitalize on
better development I'll still some
issues to solve
I could take we trade probably just
trading he wants to deal with Bishop
I think with Bishop I have just simple
move Keaney chains I mean we could just
get like a very equal position yeah so
keen each it was my first impression
there's also Bishop e6 actually I'm
Bishop e6
look Queens not defendant and c2 and
rook see it coming - almost probably
just equalizes very easily up about 40
seconds and then game I mean 9 game will
probably be equal but I'll have there's
some imbalance I have the the two-on-one
on the Queen side which sometimes is
good sometimes the pawns can be weak but
try and treat it as a good thing does
this work takes takes it works
I mean Bishop d3 expected we trade
everything you could go crazy intake and
then soccer queen she might be
considering actually maybe I should have
been a bit more careful
I mean the Bishop d3 all actually have a
choice of maybe 97 would be the most
attractive option okay so he's going for
this yeah yeah the problem is be sevens
hanging I do have Queen actually have
Queenie four okay so let's yeah let's
only move right so Queenie four might
might save me
[Music]
there's a line queen bee to repeat one
Chinese want to look into too much it's
annoying position though because I can't
easily develop interesting 94 some
rookie 7 move
you're okay 7 followed by 96 he wants to
[ __ ] about 5 the threat that would just
win immediately hmm so there's g6
to be very careful here okay so up on
time making even more loose for my king
yeah I think it's good to have the pawns
on on light squares to restrict the
bishop even though this pawns weak I
probably want to play b5 at some points
if I get the chance the Queen can always
drop back to e7 - yeah after he's not
possible yeah cuz I take here so I
should be ooh I was about to say it
should be better but it's still very
complex so he's threatening there should
be seven probably have to play rook a7
was Queen e5 as well but then rook c1 I
don't know what to do
okay southern let's try rock a7 okay
it was very tense position I might just
be losing but maybe time and save me but
the problem here I can't play b5 because
the pots pinned Knight also has a hard
time developing so maybe like a 596 he's
playing strong moves let's try this so
there is a line if he plays Knight d5 I
can play this and if takes takes takes I
made on b1 and end so it's still tricky
no no
yeah so he just moves the rook though he
has rook c4 okay I've ever okay six
actually but rookie six Bishop takes b7
I was just just a big mess for me
and they c6 any merit 96 like seasick
might be the way to go
alright so Carlos sacrificed a queen
he's all over him he's doubled up on the
bubble up night is trapped time is equal
any subscribers fleeting madness takes
its toll so listen close sure not for
very much longer
I've got to keep control how's it going
I don't know I want to play like 96 but
yeah I just worked c4 and if Roque six
Bishop takes b7 this is what I have to
go for is really not pretty
maybe Bishop takes b7 Queenie five I can
still try and fight we got Eric Rosen
and the local player from here
Carlos Perdomo all three results we have
options yes with Queenie five so that
you have twenty five I hit the Knights
I also defend the night in certain lines
guess white could take but even in that
line I have Queen takes and then there's
it takes a six Queen b6 rook c5 let's
play play this move
thanks for the bits Texas time
I mean the dream is to get like Queen
versus two rooks probably Queen versus
two rooks and pond but this is going to
be time scramble meteoric F sixes are a
nice resource if he allows me it's
taking his time too
okay
Oh ritzy to have to probably try it
though
so Queenie five so the Knights still
defended oh this is actually in the best
case scenario
I mean Brooksie five we could end up
repeating be a weird repetition I might
go for a dirty flag in that case because
what else to do
okay he's letting me off the hook
maybe this move um I have three coming
that's okay
so I have queen bee 827 safe move it's
just a matter of playing quickly now
getting initiative now my knight but
that pawn
both sides are winning but they're both
losing on time both sides with seconds
left the position on the board
irrelevant yeah this is the most
exciting game in the history of chaste
until the next time so dirty he probably
just wants to get Carlos rose find some
hand sanitizer